ああああああ
マツダピーポって言いましたはいっていう意味で今日はですね段ボールを使って
ポケモンの
エアームドを作っていこうと思います葉刈り飛行タイプの子疑問だね
まさに俺みたいな感じだね鋼の身体とハメをボツポケモ
昔の人は抜け落ちた羽を使って刀や包丁をつくっていた
頑丈で重そうな鉄の体が薄くて軽いので時速300キロで止める
ねちょっと久しぶりでちょっとアレなんですけどダンボールがだいぶたまってきたんで
まぁ今まで米対クロスであるがと作って来てね
花にポケモン還元でパパッとでエア部の木を作ろうと思いますメタグロスとが出会いが
みたいな巨大生徒によりどっちかというとこう
邪魔にならない大きさの
ar 度本当に飾ろうと思ってるいいよパーンメインカラーになるじいろサティ大量の
段ボールプールああっああんたいパカーンなんだろうね母鹿作りゃいいにょちゃ参考に
する
写真はこれでこれを作ります
8 a メロエアうおーー
体の状態を結構丸みを帯びているのでなゴールで表現は難しいです
間でこんな感じですちょっと高くだけどまあいいでしょう足に行きます
ヘルしかねーよば
ハーラーし先に足の爪部分を作ります
ちょっと今回きついな頑張ります
一つジェナーでいかないのは知ってたよ
ああああああ
金完成です
なんとか完成しましたうーん微妙 s 何とも言えない感じです
ブーブーどうぞ
労働どーぞどーぞっ4ふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇ
ふぇふぇふぇふぇふぇぶらすと
的には杏は体がやっぱ四角いはこういうところとか
こう言うとかもっとこだわってちょっと丸みを帯びで作ればもっと完成度が違っている
と思います入ってガーゼのアームぞ制作でした
ちょっと久しぶりのポケモンだったのできつかったですけどもまぁ感覚は取り戻したん
でまた危険があれば作ろうと思いますサッっと宮ねぇもうどう見た目アームのなんで
まぁ
大きいに者はぜひ皆さんも段ボールのポケモンを作ってみてくださいはがねタイプなら
意外と作れますよじゃあなぁ
&コンパクトおやすみなさい
始めやるぞ
ああああああっ